hey everybody Sean McGinnis here
alongside Ralph Fulton the creative
director on the recently announced forts
of horizon 2 Ralph obviously you guys
have moved from Colorado to southern
Europe
what part of southern Europe are we
taking a look at here wow you know we've
really said throwing a net over southern
Europe and pick the most beautiful the
most varied the most interesting places
I really just made a mixtape of southern
year for our game we picked you know the
beautiful rolling landscapes of Provence
down to the glamour of the Cote d'Azur
the South of France and then over into
northern Italy we've got Tuscany
beautiful rural landscapes there
medieval science and then we've also
thrown in the Amalfi Coast with you know
legendary driving roads and those
amazing ocean views this is when the
rewind button comes in very handy
absolutely a force us staple you know
you've got rewind obviously you can set
your assists how you prepare them we're
all about letting you play the game how
you want to play it so what was the
reasoning behind moving the game from
Colorado because one of the neat things
about the original fort surprisin is
that it kind of captured that freedom of
the open road of classic Americana
hitting you know the freeways and
driving for hours on end absolutely and
we absolutely loved that over the first
game when we started looking around for
where we could say this game we wanted
the police they could you know live up
to that ideal as well we're all about
the freedom of the open roads just being
able to point your car in any direction
and drive what we're about amazing roads
we're about amazing Vestas incredible
scenery and we found all of that and the
the Front's in the north of Italy and
that's where we chose to set our game I
guess the difference this time for the
previous game is that we have a rule
that there are only barriers that are
only walls in our game where they exist
in real life you know and what that
means is our world is just far more open
ran three times as large as the original
horizon in terms of you know drivable
space and I guess what that means is we
now have three times more space to fill
with amazing cool things to do in cars
right and what you said a moment ago
about the lack of barriers we saw that
earlier when we were driving through the
fields is that something you guys are
trying to do more of yeah absolutely so
we really wanted to achieve a truly open
world for this game and as we've
developed opportunities have just
presented themselves within it you know
so we've actually created an entirely
new race event in this game called cross
country in which you abandon routes
entirely and all the cars just race
across open country safe through fields
across hell's through forests it's a
really exciting really super fun
exclusively for horizon 2 alright and it
looks like we may be nearing the finish
line pretty soon here but before we get
there let's talk about the weather
system what sort of work went into that
and how does it affect things because
obviously driving in the rain is tricky
it is you know what as a gamer it's an
experience I've been waiting for in
Porto for a long time we're really
excited to be able to to bring it to
Horizon 2 for the first time and the
time was right for us to do that because
Xbox one really gives us the power to
build this system from the ground up
with an emphasis on really realistic
simulation we simulate everything about
weather from the way light moves through
the atmosphere from the way puddles form
on the ground the way the road dries
when the Sun comes out it's out on
realistic play so simulates it which
means that we have this really stunning
looking a big dynamic system which is
always changing up the way the world
looks and the way the road strife just
heading into the finish line right here
whoo ok so we've got a lot of smash
turbos it's really action-packed game
that's something we wanted to retain
from the original and amplify it's just
the fun of driving in an open world
we've done that I think in horizon 2
we're really excited the people are
getting their hands on it for the first
time this e3 alright Ralph well thank
you very much I believe you're gonna be
joining us on our stage show here at e3
2014 so we'll be able to check out even
more right I kind of wait all right
sounds good thank you thanks man
you